I was born and raised in Malaysia and
then in 20 2010 I left Malaysia to the
US for my University that's when I
started doing stand-up in 2015 I moved
to the UK from Chicago to London uh
because I was dating a woman who was
from Germany European woman we're not
together anymore but then I moved here
with her continued doing the stand up uh
2019 I went um full-time stand-up I
always had a day job throughout the
whole time two students to start doing
stand up in 2011 University had a day
job did stand up part-time four or five
nights a week 2019 September kind of had
like enough of a
like enough fees for me to go full time
and support myself I went full time six
months later covet hit lost all the work
I was like [__] can we curse on this yes
okay yeah I was like [__] okay I lost
all my work I have 10 months worth of
savings to to to to to live basically so
let's try to make something work online
uh at the time I had a podcast and I
also started doing YouTube so and that's
where my my character really took off uh
my character is called Uncle Roger
basically I played this middle-aged
Asian Uncle inspired by all these Asian
Boomers I see from my childhood you know
who talk a lot of [__] uh sassy attitude
but ultimately they're kind people so I
played this character online uh
critiquing
Western usually Western celebrity chefs
[__] up Asian food so the very very
first video uh that went viral was the
BBC food egg fried rice video drain it
drip what's she doing
what's she doing train the oh my God
you're killing me woman higher trainer I
just put on this orange Polo started
talking [__] and then when the video
when I posted a video I was at 7 000
subscribers that was June 2020. 7 000
subscribers and then the first week in
the video got ten thousand views oh [__]
that's pretty good yeah you know I was
like you know patting myself in the back
but later Reddit picked it up nine gag
picked it up Facebook Twitter it all
went viral in every platform Tick Tock
everywhere and so I just kept making the
videos went on a full World Tour doing
my stand up as both my character and
then as myself which is a great way to
do it because you save money on an
opening act
500 pounds per gig extra money
uh and and then and then yeah just now
we're here so I just kept making the
videos kept doing stand up now I have um
things I'm developing with other
production companies and looking to move
to LA for work in a couple months so
yeah it's exciting stuff man yeah thank
you I remember we did the same gig above
a pub yes with you above a pub with you
below I used to do my gig below a pub
and for people who wouldn't have seen
your stand up you were always one of the
people that I think everybody on the
circuit like rated as really good um
thank you you know thank you but you
know when you're good at standups it's
it's kind of hard to get ahead if you're
actually like if you're too funny you
know what I mean yeah we don't have to
get in time I have no idea what he's
talking about
I'm not saying I'm too funny but I think
sometimes sometimes especially in the
British comedy scene you have a very
theatrical culture yeah so when you
bring a show up to the fat the festival
here Edinburgh Fringe uh people want
like a theatrical structure to your show
so people who just focus on I just want
to be funny that doesn't work that well
but what helps us is because we do
online stuff funny actually goes viral
the theatrical artsy [__] harder to go
viral so I'm happy I found this little
path for myself and you did find this
little part for yourself and how has
your life changed Nigel from when we
knew you to how you are now
who has my life changed uh I use Adobe
Premiere Pro too much you know that this
drives me crazy man uh
honestly like it's just such a relief
you know because you you're just
hustling and grinding and anonymity on
the circuit yeah yeah I'm just every day
coming from a gig 11 P.M to midnight and
just walking home I have to go to my day
job the next day I wake up at seven and
I'm like will I ever be able to do this
full time you never know you know but
now the fact that you know I did a world
tour it's like 100 something shows over
50 something cities and then every I
think all the shows were sold out you
see people real life people coming to
support you you're like oh okay kind of
made it it's good it's a good feeling so
I think that's career-wise that's the
biggest change to have that that bit of
comfort and confidence that [__] will
work out you know
foreign